[Music]
cole beasley made the jump from the
dallas cowboys to the buffalo bills in
free agency and we kind of saw it coming
based upon things he said before he
became a free agent now that he's a
member of the buffalo bills he is saying
more about his concerns about the dallas
cowboys offense here's one via the
athletic i felt like it was easy for me
to be taken away in the dallas offense
really in that attack all you had to do
was bracket me because i went beyond
five yards rarely and when i did it was
from the same formation i was in the
same spot all
the time
that feeds into chris the criticism
you've had of the jason garrett offense
for a long time it's too basic it's too
predictable it's too easy to figure out
what they're doing it's too easy to come
up with ways to defend against it
because there's no imagination there's
no creativity there's no variety
everyone's in the same spot all the time
that was why dez bryant had such a hard
time finding a new team last year all
he's ever done is play x receiver in the
same offense for 10 years right no not
no creative formation use you know no
motions shifts you know dallas are one
of those teams when they break the
huddle they line up they don't do
anything to help the quarterback as far
as you know motioning changing
formations a little bit to get you know
clues as far as what the defense is
doing that's what the great offenses do
and yeah and then once they are lined up
there they've been limited and the the
plays that they run and this is one of
my concerns with the dallas cowboys is
one of the only things holding them back
there has to be more on the offensive
side of the ball so one of the reasons i
got such great respect for dak prescott
he gets very few easy completions let
alone they rely on the run game and
people sometimes think that's easier to
play quarterback that way and i've been
trying to say the last you know a few
weeks sometimes it's harder playing
quarterback that way but cole beasley
now up in buffalo with brian dayball who
comes from new england where we know
edelman amendola wes welker chris hogan
he's he's going to be you know a pig in
crap now he's going to be in the perfect
offense i almost said it i didn't say it
he's going to be very happy uh about the
plays that come his way and all the
different designs they have for him
here's what beasley said about the
buffalo offense in this offense we move
around it's going to be harder to key on
one guy here it's a lot better than
where i was before i'll get to run
routes from spots i've never gotten to
run routes from it's going to be sweet
i'm excited about it and you know back
to that dallas offense talking about the
absence of movement and shifts i think
back to the 70s when tom landry was the
coach and they would do that thing where
the offensive lineman would like to
stand up before they go to the
three-point stance they were always into
those little things that would that
would get people thinking and just a
little style here or there it really is
basic meat potatoes for jason garrett
maybe different this year with a new
offensive coordinator and kellen moore
he's never been an offensive coordinator
before he's only been an assistant coach
for what this is his second year yeah
but that's the challenge as jason
garrett tries to get his next contract
can they do enough with that offense to
make jerry jones the owner of the team
conclude that jason garrett should stick
around for another four or five years
after this one yeah that'll be the big
question and and you know mike when we
talk about all this they don't need to
do a lot they don't need to reinvent the
wheel you know because they are
extremely talented and more times than
not they can physically win the battle
up front and just impose their physical
will with bigger stronger better people
uh but there's going to be those handful
of games where they're not going to be
able to do that a lot of the divisional
playoff game right and yeah you like to
go and say okay you know in those
situations we got enough creativity on
the offensive side of the ball different
formations different cheap ways to get
amari cooper and other receivers the
ball that okay we don't always have to
rely on ezekiel elliott and zach martin
dominating the football game that way
puts a lot of pressure on the franchise
to play that way week in and week out if
they could just bring a little bit more
to the passing game
with this talent they have on their team
already i mean dallas is they're one of
the most talented teams in football they
could be up there for a number one seed
and number two seed in the nfc playoff
conversation
one of the comments cole beasley made
back before he became a free agent
honestly the front office pushes who
they want to get the ball to i haven't
been a huge priority in that regard
maybe that will change but i'm not sure
more balls come my way in the two-minute
drill where nothing is planned so look
the the cowboys deny that stephen jones
jerry jones we don't push who gets the
ball now i remember
when terrell owens was in dallas he
claimed that tony romo and jason whitney
used to get together and come up with
ways to get the ball more to whitten and
look any time the priority is anything
other than throw the ball to the open
receiver i'm concerned and and beasley's
been there so
he may be wrong his his viewpoint may be
skewed but that's what he believed and
once he made that tweet on january 22nd
this guy's not going to be back right
he's not going to be back and he's not
going to be back he's going to be with
the buffalo bill yeah no he's not going
to be back you're right and that that
certainly helped uh help you know don't
let the door hit you on the way out
right that was one of those kind of
comments there but um yeah with with
with beasley uh you know oh this is what
i want to say you know i i don't believe
that as far as what he's trying to
accuse the cowboys i don't think jerry
jones of the jones family is going oh
you know hey don't throw the ball to
cole beasley you know get all the plays
for amari cooper no the offense is set
up for the guys on the outside like
amari cooper and whoever to get the ball
anyways two yeah there's not enough
plays for the slot receivers like in new
england or the new orleans saints have
to get those kind of guys the ball you
know and then i i go three dallas also
goes okay well we're not a like a pass
at 40 times a game we got amari cooper
we traded for him so they went out of
their way to get him the ball at times
so i think it was just more of the
culture the climate of the team the
offense i don't know i don't i really
don't believe that the owners were
calling down saying get everybody else
the ball other than cole beasley
well the thing is one of the perks of
being a billionaire who owns a football
team sometimes you don't have to be well
you're right sometimes you don't right
yes we traded for amari we like amari we
like amara cooper and you're right the
coaches will get the clue and i think
they got the clue as soon as they traded
a first round pick for them that oh this
is our new shiny toy we better try to
make the family happy and get get him
the ball and get him off as far as stats
are concerned
of course the flip side to that by
pumping him up that way now it's time to
sign into a new contract and it's gonna
be a little more expensive because you
have seen amari cooper perform better in
dallas than he had for most of his time
with the raiders so that's gonna end up
making it more expensive to keep around
maybe they should have waited to give
the directive to throw the ball to omari
cooper so much so after they signed him
to a new contract either way you know
hey sometimes decisions are
are
made by influence not directive yeah
just kind of the influence you get the
idea of what the boss wants and if you
don't give the boss what the boss wants
he's not gonna be your boss for much
longer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports